why is the King's dagger destined for
greatness and why does rhaenyra remind
us so much of Arya Stark House of the
Dragon is here here's what you missed in
episode one house of the Dragon takes
place
172 years before the birth of Daenerys
Targaryen and is a very faithful
adaptation of George RR Martin's 2018
book Fire and Blood according to
showrunner Ryan Condell beginning about
halfway through its sweeping narrative
part of the appeal of House of the
Dragon is the chance to see King's
Landing at a time of relative peace and
prosperity the red keep is brand new and
the dragon pit is in its Heyday with
several adult specimens kept within its
cavernous walls Cyrax is growing quickly
which will soon be as large as curraxis
this is the same Dragon pit we see
during Game of Thrones in utter ruin as
Daenerys John and Tyrion reveal their
captive white in an attempt to convince
Cersei to join their fight against the
White Walkers the dragon pit ruins our
also where the series finale takes place
during which a newly formed Council
nominates their next ruler putting the
final nail in the coffin of the Dragon
riding family's domination that their
ruins in Game of Thrones however means
the dragon pit fell into disrepair while
the targaryens still occupied the throne
depending on how closely House of the
Dragon Hues to the books and how many
seasons it runs we may eventually get to
see its demise play out in live action
yeah that's the iconic iron throne in
House of the Dragon it just looks a lot
more like what George R Martin
originally had in mind than the seed of
swords as it appeared in Game of Thrones
in the books Martin describes the Iron
Throne as ugly asymmetrical and huge and
the house of the Dragon version fits
that description nicely in his lore it
was made of the swords of one thousand
enemies vanquished by King aegon and
melted by his dragon valerion as
impressive and intimidating as the iron
throne in Game of Thrones was it wasn't
a monstrosity that had sprawled all over
the throne room the way it does in House
of the Dragon there's another Throne
related detail later in the episode that
speaks to Martin's World building King
viserys has a nasty wound on his back
that he attributes to the throne and
when we see him actually sitting in it
he cuts his hand on the armrest could
that be a foreshadowing of some bad news
to come rhaenyra clearly wants to lead
but she seems more interested in making
her own history on the back of her
Dragon than she is in studying the
history of those who came before her her
friend and companion Allison Hightower
implores her to recite back the story of
Princess nymeria to please the SEPTA at
first rhaenyra Bluffs her way through it
but when pressed she effortlessly
rattles off the bullet points nymeria
she says fled her Valerian pursuers with
10 000 ships across the narrow sea
arrived in Dorne and destroyed her own
Fleet to show her people they were
finished running she married Lord Morse
Martel to unite door born under one flag
for the first time while few women
inherited Thrones on the mainland
nymeria saw to it that lines of
succession were gender blind after her
death her daughter ruled nymeria and
perhaps her Legend may sound familiar to
fans of Game of Thrones Arya Stark named
her direwolf nymeria after the warrior
Queen amiria
House of the Dragon chose to highlight
the tale of nymeria is no accident her
strength and ambition not only mirror
rhaenyra's her husband also mirrors one
of Rainier's potential suitors during
the name day tournament a Victorious
Kristen Cole reveals himself to be
dornish which is surprising enough to
elicit a reaction from the young women
rhaenyra knowing her history brings to
mind Sansa Stark being quizzed by a
Septa in season 1 of Game of Thrones and
her correctly identifying the Builder of
two of King landing's landmarks built
the iron throne
egg in the Conqueror and who built the
red keep make of the crew speaking of
maegor the cruel in the first episode of
House of the Dragon when Otto Hightower
brings up the issue of succession at the
small Council following the tragic
deaths of the king's wife and day old
son he warns that Prince Damon should
never sit on the Iron Throne Damon would
be a second maegor or worse
he is impulsive and violent only one
episode in it's painfully clear that the
hand of the king and the prince are
bitter Rivals so his input should be
taken with a grain of salt so who was
maegor the cruel he's only briefly
mentioned in the Game of Thrones TV
series but we learned he built the red
keep and used Wildfire against his
enemies the books tell us he was the
Second Son of aegon the Conqueror and
the third Targaryen king of Westeros he
came to power after the death of his
weaker older brother who tried to
co-rule alongside him he murdered his
own nephew to prevent his claim to the
throne after the red keep was finished
maegor had all the workers killed to
preserve the secrets of its blueprints
by the end of his six tyrannical years
in power he'd managed to unite almost
the entire realm against him Damon is an
opportunistic and violent womanizer but
it remains to be seen if he can live up
to maegor's deranged awfulness
princess rhaenyra is frustrated by her
father's obsession with producing a male
successor and she seems ambivalent at
best about her future as a wife and
mother she laments that no matter what
she does she'll never be a son and when
a son is imminent Alison asks if she's
worried about her position she says no
but it's obvious the real answer is yes
so when viseris summons her to tell her
he's decided to name her his Heir she's
genuinely taken aback the king even
apologizes to her for wasting many years
wanting for a son when she was already
worthy of the crown viserys warns her
that the Iron Throne is the most
dangerous seat in the Seven Kingdoms
before he holds a ceremony to officially
deem her princess of Dragonstone during
which the Lords bend the knee in both
Fire and Blood and House of the Dragon
rhaenyra serves as cup Bearer for the
King's small Council this position might
seem like a task that would be given to
an intern but it's actually a place of
honor and issue of trust that's bestowed
upon Noble boys and girls it's more
explicit in the book but by keeping
rhaenyra around him as he conducts his
business viserys is exposing her to
what's essentially classified
information as well as to the Daily
goings-on of a monarch a disguised Arya
Stark in another parallel to rhaenyra
served as Tywin Lannister's cup Bearer
on the show not in the novels because he
recognized that she was Highborn and
enjoyed her wit
the gigantic skull of valerion is no
small detail but its significance and
previous appearances may have been lost
on some audiences the dragon that
belonged to aegon the Conqueror maegor
the cruel and finally viserys himself
valerion the black dread was the largest
dragon in the post-conquest era and as
viserys explains the last living thing
to flee valyria before the Doom the King
asks his daughter what she sees when she
looks upon his remains raniera answers
that she sees them the targaryens she
grasps that their family has exercised
influence over the kingdoms because they
can control the Fearsome beasts but
their fortunes rise and fall with the
creatures to whom they've tethered their
Destiny viserys sees that they're as
wonderful as they are terrible and
doubts that his people should have ever
tried to tame them they're a power men
should never have trifled with readers
of the books and Game of Thrones viewers
May recognize this opposing skull which
would put any natural history museum
display to shame among other instances
Cersei plots her attack on Daenerys
dragons from valerion's Crypt and the
skull can be seen behind Tyrion as he
plans the dragon pit Summit with Jaime
Lannister in other words for all the
destruction that's befallen King's
Landing and the Seven Kingdoms At Large
over the past two centuries the remains
of the black dread still rest in peace
if a little worse for wear
in the final moments of the House of the
Dragon Premiere King viserys makes sure
that his daughter princess rhaenyra
understands just how precarious and
loaded with responsibility her role as
Queen will be he describes aegon the
conqueror's vision in which a coming
cataclysm will begin with a long harsh
winter and bring with it a threat from
the North like the world has never seen
he tells her that for the Seven Kingdoms
to survive a Targaryen must remain on
the throne presumably to fight the dark
force with their dragons at this point
he reveals the Valyrian steel blade at
his hip while all Valyrian steel can
kill White Walkers the threat to which
king viserys was referring this isn't
just any Valyrian steel dagger it's the
Valyrian steel dagger a would-be
assassin uses it to try to murder Bran
Stark in Game of Thrones when he just
barely fails the weapon ends up in the
Stark's possession and it follows them
throughout the show Catelyn takes it to
King's Landing to try and solve the plot
against her family its ownership however
remains a mystery it could have been
littlefingers or tyrions the former says
he lost it to the latter in a bet bran
eventually gives it to Arya who famously
wields it in the battle for Winterfell
to finish off the night King about whom
aegon's dream warned him it's she who
holds it still as far as we know but
nearly two centuries earlier it was the
property of King viserys
laughs